When I go to an Islamic museum and I
went to one where there are scriptures
written all over the wall in Melbourne,
I noticed that they're all from the
beginning of the Quran. Talk to me about
that and talk to me about the law of
abrogation. Sure. The law of abrogation,
which is the the most important part,
which in Arabic is called the naskh
wal-mansukh, which means that which is
abrogated and that which abrogates, is
basically the idea that, okay, so the
Quran is supposed to be believed that
Muhammad recited it. That's what the
word Quran means, to recite, according
to what Gabriel, the angel, told him to
recite. And it's supposedly based on,
you know, literally the words of Allah
as delivered to the Supposedly, it's
almost like the Mormon idea, there's a
stele with the same words in heaven in
Arabic. So, the Quran was recited
Muhammad supposedly gets his first
revelation around 610 and they continue
until 632 when he dies, okay? Now, they
got just thrown into a book later on as
the Quran and they were actually
organized by length. A surah is
essentially a chapter and they just put
the longest chapter first and the
shortest at the very end. If you read it
like that, it literally makes no sense.
I mean, at best it's poetry and you
don't even know what's going on, which
is another reason why the hadith is so
important cuz the hadith talks about
events in his life
>> Right. Right. that then Muslims
correspond to what's being said in the
Quran and then they try to make sense of
it. But, there are contradictions within
the Quran. So, the apologists that you
probably meet often will tell you things
like, "The Quran says there's no
compulsion in religion.
>> Exactly. You have your religion, I have
mine." Right.
>> That is in the Quran, okay? But, here's
the thing, Muhammad In Muhammad's
career, when he started preaching and
speaking the Quran around 610, he was
living in Mecca. And so, the Islamic
scholars have differentiated two phases.
There's the revelations, the verses that
came out when he was in Mecca, the older
ones, and then there's the ones when he
went to Medina. Now, when he was in
Mecca, he was outnumbered, he was weak,
he had at most something like 100
followers and he was being bullied and
pushed around by the pagan Quraysh
tribe. That's when he said, "You have
your religion, I have mine. Let's all
respect each other, okay? Let's learn to
coexist. There's no compulsion in
religion." That's when that came out.
Then, he did in 622 the Hijra, where he
went
>> Oh, that's right.
>> He went to Medina, and now he became a
tribal warlord. He became strong, he had
followers, and then all of a sudden God
started or Allah started giving him more
militant, more aggressive, offensive,
going on the offensive verses.
>> And those are in the end of the Quran.
So, yes yes, because it's now his later
time, right? Yes, so I asked my Quran
teacher this,
that there's no
the law of abrogation isn't in the
Quran. No, there is actually a verse
that says something about you know, we
give you something, but when a better
thing comes along, we'll give you that.
>> Oh, interesting.
>> Okay, so the idea is Allah is giving
Muhammad these rules as he goes along,
but as Muhammad's circumstances change,
Muhammad Allah gives him a different a
different modus operandi to follow. So,
if Muhammad is weak, uh you know, then
he obviously is telling him, "Well,
don't rock the boat. Tell them Yeah.
>> we all live." Now you're strong, well
now so the verses, for example, that I
said 9:29 and 9:5, okay, those are the
latest. It's Sura 9 uh Surat al-Tawbah.
Those are the most militant verses.
They're the ones that say 9:29 says,
"Fight the people of the book until they
pay tribute or die." 9:5 is even more
open-ended. It just says, "Lay in wait
for the pagans wherever you find them,
kill them, ambush them, and take them as
slaves." Okay? Those are much later.
That's the final word. So, it's seen now
amongst Muslims that this is Allah's
final word. He gave him the more
tolerant ones earlier on because it was
necessary. And the other view, which is
actually even more dangerous, is Muslims
say this, and I've encountered this
often. They say, "Yes, both versions,
the Mecca and Medina Quran, meaning the
tolerant one and the more violent one,
are still perfectly applicable, and it
depends on where the Muslim finds
himself in society. So, if you find
yourself in a weakened position, you
should preach the peaceful ones. You
have your religion, I have mine. If you
find yourself stronger, then you should
also go on the offensive. And I'll I'm
going to share with you a final amusing
anecdote, which deals with a Somali.
>> And um this is back at the Library of
Congress where I worked. And uh you
know, he was a pious Muslim. And I
actually liked and respected him. I know
we we don't share the same theology and
philosophy ultimately. Okay, but you
know, he was he was a no-nonsense kind
of family guy and very traditional.
Okay. And we would have debates though
theological debates. He was kind of like
the patriarch of his clan.
>> And I mentioned all this because he was
telling me, "No, you're wrong." He
seemed radical, but he would tell me,
"No, Islam is peace. It's not" He would
do all that. So, one time in a
cafeteria, I kept pushing him and
telling him this story. And I kept
saying, "Well, what about the Mecca
verses verses and the abrogation?" And I
said, "Mecca is when Muhammad's weak,
and this is how he asked." And he
finally got frustrated and he said,
"Well, what do you want from me? I live
in Mecca."
Meaning DC. Meaning I'm outnumbered. I'm
around infidels. Of course, I'm going to
say this. Okay? Oh, that's interesting.
So, So, do you believe that peaceful
Western Muslims are practicing taqiyya?
I I think
>> Can you say the word? taqiyya taqiyya
Yeah, and that's another Do you deceit?
Do you believe that peaceful non-Muslims
peaceful Western Muslims are practicing
>> I believe a lot of them could be. And I
know a lot of them have been caught
doing this. You know, there's stories of
I remember writing about a story in
Turkey where a group of Muslims went to
a church and Christians are my very
minority there. And they went to a
church and they got to know the pastor
and his family and they feigned interest
and some of them got baptized. And then
they got busted. It was all a big plot
to murder him. Okay? Like that's the the
lengths they went to just to do it. So,
deception in Islam is a permissible
thing and especially in the context of
taqiyya. Okay?
>> service of the religion only though,
right?
>> The thing about taqiyya is its most
authentic expression is you are being,
you know, persecuted.
>> So, it's very different than
Christianity. If I'm If a Christian
comes to a Muslim, puts a sword to his
head, and says, "I
I want you to renounce Muhammad." You
know, the the traditionally a Christian
martyr says, "No." and he dies. Right.
Right.
>> Muhammad himself actually advocated,
"Yeah, tell them renounce me, renounce
Islam, and uh do whatever you have to
do." Okay, so it's a very pragmatic
take. But, yes, the taqiyya or the
deception in general is a real thing. I
wouldn't say every single Muslim's doing
it. I think a lot of real Muslims
actually are dissatisfied with Islam. I
think they would leave it if they could
without repercussions. So, I think some
of them are also they could be uh
sincere. Are there So, is there any
actual data or concrete evidence of of
rates of deceit? Uh I think that's
>> you get that? I don't think I mean, can
you imagine Europe actually trying to
conduct that kind of survey?
>> [laughter]
>> No. How politically incorrect that would
be. But, I do know I've I've read about
often times, you know, a Muslim
terrorist
>> lie on the survey, so Yeah, exactly.
But, also I've read about Muslim
terrorists being arrested, and then they
go through a rehabilitation program in
the UK where they tell, you know, they
they give them moderate versions and
have them play ping-pong.
>> Malmö, Sweden, they have the same thing.
>> Yeah, and uh and then they pass with
flying colors, and they go, "Okay,
you're" and then week later they let
them out and they go and commit another
terrorist crime.
>> Right. Right.
So, uh you know, it it's just it's
unfortunate because Islamic deception
mixed with Western stupidity and naivety
is just a really bad combo.
Bring back the
>> [music]
>> Bring back
Bring back
>> [music]
>> and the